prepare to be absolutely horrified
because Kim kardashian-west Kourtney
Kardashian and Scott Disick all took
their turn at snapchats new baby face
filter and it is all kinds of creepy
[Music]
yep that's court and using the face
filter weird right
well Kim was so shocked by the clip she
posted it to her Instagram story
commenting on how much her older sister
looks like her five-year-old daughter
North um I think this deserves a
side-by-side she's not wrong Court does
look a lot like little north of course
Kim had to get in on the action too
Kim looking like a baby with a chic bob
and an adult woman's voice is going to
haunt my nightmares for an eternity
thanks for that and the rattle that is
just overkill
oh it literally look like Chicago auntie
Coco
I love my mommy she's the best I'll
cosign Kim with a baby filter looks just
like Kim's baby this seems like a dub
right anyway next up it was Scott's turn
Scott and Kourtney share three kids
together and when the camera hit his mug
that beard disappeared and it was almost
like we were looking at their
nine-year-old son Mason what do you look
like there's a baby am I the only one
who hates this filter like I hate it
it's so creepy but that doesn't mean
that I don't want to try it yep
still hate it I may not like it but it
is entertaining right especially to see
these ones looking so much like they're
itty bittys of course this family keeps
us entertained all the time and you can
count on et to help you keep up with the
Kardashians so make sure to subscribe to
all things et until next time I'm Hallie
Stevens
bye for now
[Music]
[Applause]